Please welcome Ron G
to "The Next Level."
How are you doing, man?
- Yeah, what's up, bro?
How you doin', man?
- Good to see you, man.
Man, my life is
incredible right now.
- Incredible?
- Yeah.
I'm trying to be
unaffordable real soon.
Before you get
unaffordable, let
me tell them where you're from.
- OK.
Ron G was born and raised
in Columbia, South Carolina.
Ay.
You started comedy in Atlanta.
Right?
I did.
And when you were
in Atlanta, you
were encouraged to
try stand-up comedy
for one night by your cousin.
- Yes.
Is that correct?
Yeah, it was Apollo night--
Uptown Comedy Club, when
it was on Peachtree.
Uptown?
On Sunday night.
Uptown.
And yeah, I had one
joke, and it was terrible.
And I got on stage, and
halfway through my set,
all I heard was, boo!
And then I walked outside,
and this dude was like, man,
you terrible.
You ain't never gonna
be funny, little nigga.
- Wow.
- And I was like--
that was back when
I used to curse.
I was like, F you there, man!
He was like, F you gets
you killed, and walked off.
I was like, you know what?
I'ma just go to the car.
You just going to go
about your business?
Yeah, that's-- yeah, yeah.
Ron, you moved from
Atlanta to Los Angeles.
RON G: Yeah.
- Is this true?
Because I heard this.
And if it is true,
I'm blown away by it.
- OK.
- I heard you won an Emmy.
I did.
You won an Emmy?
I won an Emmy.
Yes, I did.
For what?
What did you win an Emmy for?
I was a consulting producer
for a show called "United
Shades of America" for CNN.
Wow.
And we won our Emmy season
two, "United Shades" for CNN.
And I won an Emmy on
my first producing gig.
- That's unreal.
- Yeah.
I wrote the funny for the show.
Unreal, man.
Yes, sir.
I heard you won one, too.
Did you win one?
No, I didn't win
no damn Emmy, man.
- Wait.
- What kind of mess is that?
You didn't win an Emmy?
I didn't win no damn Emmy.
All these TV and movies you've
done, you never won an Emmy?
No, I ain't never
won no god damn Emmy.
Well, I'll let
you borrow mine.
Ain't this about a bitch.
Ain't this about a--
I'm just saying.
Now I want an Emmy.
RON G: OK.
I want one, now.
[laughs]
No, I love it, man.
Listen, Ron, first and
foremost, I'm a friend.
Always been a fan, man.
And you know what?
I think your style of
comedy, dude, is amazing.
I think you've
grown as a comedian.
Thank you.
I think that right now, it's--
it's obvious that you're ready
for the next level.
RON G: Absolutely.
This is no-brainer, man.
I'm trying to be unaffordable.
Go out there and
make yourself happy.
Man-- hey, man.
Make god proud, man.
Man!
Hey, you better go
flippy-floppy flip it.
All right?
[inaudible] Ron G,
get out of here!
I didn't mean to stand
in your V. I'm sorry.
Get out of here, man.
It's all right.
He said, I didn't mean to
stand in your V, he said.
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and
gentlemen, "The Next Level"